Hey Youtubers it's Charlie!
This is going to be Doctor Who Episode 6 video.
Maisie Williams part 2.
It was a continuation of last week's story.
Although it was kind of Iike it's own self-contained
story, a bookend for her on the show.
I felt like it was a really good chance after
last week's episode that she could be a potential
new companion but there was some interesting
things in the doctor said like some interesting
speeches he had in this episode they change
the way I felt about that so we can we can
talk about as we get to spoilers just careful
if you haven't seen the episode yet in new
round of the Doctor Who giveaway starts now
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video starting
with number five Maisie Williams is the nightmare
child and she and the doctor both tried to
rob the same carriage without realizing it
who else thought of the nightmare child from
the end of time like the David Tennant shout
out clearly Russell T Davies had no idea that
Maisie Williams will be cast on the show Sunday
but I like the way Moffat Canal like we Maisie
Williams character into Doctor Who history
it just because she is functionally immortal
even though the last speech the doctor had
with her was rather hopeful the ambiguous
end tag leaves it open to just about anything
you can imagine but I really like the energy
in this opening scene just the comedy of the
Dr. robbing the stagecoach and then not realizing
that someone else is robbing at the same time
I do believe there's a robbery happening right
now sometimes it's hard to tell where the
doctor just doesn't care enough to pay attention
to what's going on around them and when he's
purposefully acting stupid but on a number
for the shield or explains what's happened
to her in the last 800 years in the Dr. reads
her journals so all very sad things but she
does mention a really cool historical event
the game of thrones also borrows a little
bit from George RR Martin just takes from
real world history when his writing game of
thrones like the war of the roses or the hundred
years war and that's what Maisie Williams
mentioned in this episode the shield or kind
of took responsibility for ending the war
you could think of her as being the Joan of
arc figure in that just because Joan of arc
was a big figure during the hundred years
war you fired 10,000 you're an expert I don't
need to be immortal I'm just really awesome
that you get the comedy death montage were
like everybody tries to kill her for helping
people she's a witch drowned her that ACs
primal what happened to the sad part though
is is the doctors reading her journals is
just the sorrow she feels is the people she
loves die off in yes she did have actual children
like she did give birth to children that's
what these are for I will endure but no more
children that event in particular was during
the plague and when the doctors telling her
about things coming like you know big big
things that are gonna be crazy in the future
the show run into he mentions the Terileptils
and the great fire of London the doctor and
the running into the terileptils in like 1666
that's also the same year that the great fire
of London happen to you name dropped really
really just about anything from Doctor Who
history that she would potentially run into
in the future girl the fireplace it really
just depends on where his shoulder lives in
the world on the number three the doctor and
his shoulder versus Sam's life and his band
of robbers this is mostly done for comedy
but there was a huge doctor's daughter shout
out I'm surprised that in Seymour Jenny jokes
on twitter when the episode was happening
just because Sam was making fun of the Dr.
for being sold what you brought your father
with you know not the puns know banter turns
out the doctor really doesn't like ponds of
course she is not the actual doctor's daughter
so many people thought that she might be of
the she was announced for the show that I
feel like they might have written this and
just to poke fun at that on the number to
meet Leandro from Delta Leonidas who is trained
to shield her into getting his amulet the
eye of Hades back so that he can open a portal
for his people I'm kinda wondering if the
shows going to bring them back or Maisie Williams
just because the titles of the finale are
heaven sent in hell-bent in this episode was
all about opening a portal possibly to help
there was a lot of verbal wordplay about going
to other planes of existence and hell but
presumably they destroy the same letter the
doctor rendered it inert after they save Sam's
my fusing the of the chip to the finale titles
could be a complete coincidence I think it
has something to do with Gala frame you could
also have more to do with Maisie Williams
character in the Delta Leonidas the gallows
humor was kind of funny I'd I did feel Maisie
Williams emotional arc in the episode if it
was all about her like slowly, turning into
a time Lord type person lose someone you just
didn't care about humanity that much like
how how immortality kinda drains that out
if you that's is where the doctor so special
because he still does have empathy you could
make a lot of time Lord references to Maisie
Williams character but time Lords act a little
more superior you just kind of burnt out on
earth chooses like I'm on board I want I want
out here I want something exciting I want
to feel something again but finally on my
number one WTF moment a shield or is going
to keep her eyes on the doctor and she shows
up in one of Cloris photos in present-day
so regardless of what you think about the
emotional arc in the episode whether whether
or not it landed with you or you like the
other characters I feel like they ended things
on a really good node it just be very ambiguous
in that Maisie Williams can totally come back
they can also just got a writer off in the
distance I think a lot of it just depends
on scheduling and in contracts and stuff like
that but the energy between her and the doctors
really interesting because she is like it's
your friends you need to watch out for so
if you want to take it is like like a hopeful
moment you could draw parallels to the impossible
girl storyline were Clar like all over time
and space card just tries to save the doctor
from certain situations like to try to help
them out whenever she can in the case of a
shield or it makes it sound like she's doing
that from the background like lesson in obvious
way than Clar that it like I'm standing here
in the background just keeping an eye on things
making sure everything's okay but just to
talk about Maisie Williams potentially being
the next companion I felt like that final
scene with the doctor through a lot of water
on that theory just in being that the doctor
was saying people like us need to surround
ourselves with normal people that they don't
lose their connection to humanity so that
like that's the show like the writers and
Moffat just saying that no Maisie Williams
isn't going to be the next companion but she
will come back because she's a mortal should
be like Captain Jack who also got a big big
shout out in that speech to shield her spent
the whole episode just like throwing of the
doctors face I'm I'm waiting for you to take
you with me want you take you with me and
he says because it won't end well if he ever
forget how things like that and just look
at the face of Bo for Captain Jack but if
they were able to leach Jack's immortality
out during torchwood then I am suppose you
could think that it's possible for a shield
or to die to she says that in the episode
you like hopefully he'll kill me quickly but
yours do kinda wonder like is when you see
the face of Bo your life more clearly he has
his own mortality back so he doesn't end up
dying those are just inconsistencies the timeline
that future show runners a lot to step around
let me know what was your favorite moment
from the episode in a like gap just after
watching that final speech with the doctor
in the end tag with Maisie Williams do you
think that she has a chance of being the next
companion or do you think that whole speech
was about her not being the next companion
I love her in the episode like I love Maisie
Williams and Doctor Who is it's interesting
character that you could weave into Doctor
Who in a bigger way if she ever does want
to come back I almost feel like she's a little
too famous to be the companion using they
pick someone this a little bit more of an
up and comer and she's just kind of 40 relatively
well-established thanks to game of thrones
and some of the film work that she's done
as for the spinoff series I would say that
she is also fair game to show up on that to
but that feels like it's going to be smaller
than the main show so I'm not expecting to
see her on that like that monster Hunter spinoff
of the developing so there any other Easter
eggs in the episode you saw that I didn't
mention like 100 years war Dr. Stoddard terror
lentils just be sure to add them in the comments
below next week's episode is like the beginning
of the Saigon episode I believe that's also
a two-parter and it's the return of Osgood
I think were feeling like it might be's I
got Osgood because they're billing it as is
Saigon revolution so like something is going
on in Saigon culture on earth congratulations
to this week's giveaway winner Beowulf Adranor
you and a $20 Amazon gift card be sure to
private message me on the back and my channels
and get your contact info so what I'm going
to do next is is tonight on the trying get
my Gotham video out tomorrow will be relatively
normal just get a game of thrones walking
dead later that night so be sure to subscribe
to get everything we can debate the future
Maisie Williams in the comments really hope
that she comes back soon small chance that
she might even show up for the end of the
year but I feel like this was kind of intended
to be a bookend of her time on Doctor Who
that this episode in particular just in case
you haven't seen it in related Doctor Who
news David Tennant in the Jessica Jones trailer
you can click here to watch that he is super
creeptastic and you can click here for the
Star Wars episode seven trailer.
Thanks so much for watching, everybody high
five and I'll see you tonight!